should I do an intro do you want to do
an intro I don't care don't care
so whatever elaqid bad as a ninja okay
okay so welcome back to mount your
friends mia can't play these long ago we
were first yeah which couldn't number
one wouldn't its own xbox i don't
remember it but i think like no bub
played it like literally right after yes
each a message i thinkI you did right
didn't he yeah yeah he's pissed off
about it's like god damn you yeah yeah
so Steve's in your face yeah I always
have his fans like up in my face about
playing its games
oh no you copy you copy over hex or Nova
I do I do a lot apparently we got you
better than that I am
no I say you were saying this game is
out on Steam now yes I'm Steve it's been
updated Scott new things other than just
coming the goat and and the menu and
that's a bunch of neat stuff yeah and
the menu makes it but slab yeah yeah
this was gonna say let's go through menu
just listen to it I could be but
slapping it could be flapping it could
be a lot of things it could be I don't
want to get into it so I actually heard
that you know the penis dangling yeah
was just a bug and really thought it was
he thought it was so funny that he went
with a haggis had a bug is it supposed
to be a leg or something I don't think
it was supposed to be dangling like a
ragdoll that much I think he had a
little dangling intended you know yeah
cuz it has to be real makes the whole
game just act it is the game and I
people praise the [ __ ] out of this game
like people I just like this game is the
[ __ ] I think they're mesmerized by the
twirling of the penis I guess but it's
this weird to me I like people are
criticizing goat simulator so much but
this game is the [ __ ] for it summaries
yeah I guess this is more of a party
game and that's why all right we should
play all right so I get to make my
character or yeah you can uh you can
edit your team if you want to how do I
do that
see ya just gonna do that really quick
yeah okay yeah customer I've already
made a few so you should now I mean I
want him to look good you can import
heads I don't know how you do it yet but
it'd be amazing to have your own head
yes God do you want to give that a try I
think we could just set it at this part
oh that's funny I don't know how you do
it like it says you can import it but
wow it's probably you just have a PNG
image yeah I would assume it's and then
you place it in one of the folders yeah
so that's try to really quick oh you
know if I have a yeah do well no this
computer dang it that could make one
real quick oh yeah today gets more sorry
you don't speak Swedish okay on three
one two three
I should i clap after but it was perfect
sync I know all right start a simulated
sports like experience so this is Mount
your friends seem later is that what
they're saying actually 20 minutes this
but the faces on people I'm waiting for
pewds it says I need to press Start to
begin and I didn't so what the [ __ ] oh
there we go oh god where are you going
my go this way yeah Mike what kind of
relationship do you guys have I see what
she's got there it's an egg don't worry
yeah I promise I don't that sharesies
weird thing with eggs and putting them
in your panties
there we go you're welcome goat now I
wanna get a good grip here that's a good
start
oh I'm sorry for being terrible like
this this game get harder or am I just
like did I get worse because I don't
know
onaji I can see your nipples don't say
that to my guy from please go into the
right not straight up what does that
mean to the right past a lot of the
white lon
oh oh but we still have to touch to go
yeah oh this is hard man you must touch
the goat okay well let me put one right
there my foot will go right in goddamnit
beat it
god you're like super sticky right it's
like you won't yeah your girls the
grounds take care of them before before
you kind of float in [ __ ] yeah come on
over do it
grab that goat what are you doing
mounting that Cooper what are you gonna
do they don't you go near my gift [ __ ]
how you doing nice tapping that ass mmm
told you like these okay oh I got em no
see you got better but never mind we got
the wind against us I think that's the
thing maybe yeah till the storm level
myself I don't my stuck on a my oh yeah
you picked storm Ken you can't just
[ __ ] do it it's just the background
no it's the stormy it's a storm all
right yeah let me grab that dingdong you
see what I'm going for right that is
really [ __ ] annoying
come on yeah okay but yes yes this is
loving music don't put your face there
please oh how it happened the D's on the
Dee Dee's under D what all right yeah of
course I didn't yeah look at that fish
yeah fish you customize the junk yeah
yeah I didn't actually customize it like
this really yeah any game where you can
customize your junk is a good game in my
book
a game yeah notice how like the goat
like he painted outside the frame yeah
you spent so much time working on the
junk that we really haven't produced to
the to the right they're like barely
even out there yeah now we're talking
let me leave the fish out there for you
no thanks
ma yeah so you have finally I haven't
one team consisted of a lot of mites yes
oh and you were making your team where
you hit in the head button yeah you were
okay it could be I [ __ ] up or it could
be a queered coincidence did you say
yeah it could be I am really terrible
over my sister I wish I wish I hadn't
someone else to be honest so many things
to handle here alright
you play with the keyboard still you
know you please use a controller I think
of easier yeah probably without the
keyboard that goat maybe look so at
peace I here's that piece anyone
controlling this many junked men junk in
junk twin and women like the face you
picked out forward to she's like I'll
keep bowing there no matter what double
fit never release the fish actually I
have to Oh God we went through all of
this effort for that yeah I have my
entire team for some reason I only got
my just keep get her okay oh my god I'm
like another one that's weird see okay
alright you want Congrats yeah I win can
I join you
I'm best yeah I'm here okay let's do a
classic one what just wants me to stare
at my girlfriend's dick I guess so
but her name is she's known as Virgil
this time oh that's a good one
am i holding anything what am i holding
Toby Toby what are you doing here nice
sexy buddy you got there - hey Toby
Turner oh my god nice boobs by the way
they have a cut some mites yeah putting
on mud said that's great wait here we go
there's some og stuff if I can let go
okay come on yeah yeah don't let go w
they hey you can't believe wait how's it
going how's he talk how's it going
everybody it talks to a proper condom
put in call of duty call of duty I do
with Morgan Freeman talking to this
hilarious do some [ __ ] Freeman
impressions one day make player yeah hi
everybody I'm mark applauds they will go
play something blablabla no actually
sounded kind of like oh damn markiplier
never would hi alright I can't I can't
no one can
you did it pretty game was a great
dingdong I just want to point that out
what cast number 1 ding dong yeah
actually this is exactly the same ding
dong as everyone else we'll see you next
time everybody bye bye
if that is not true I like in you and I
both picked sure can [ __ ] let your
nipples are so white no way think I mean
eat
hey everybody ampere me Mitch give me I
want it I want to touch mark it make it
bigger me all that blood slap noise oh
snap this but make stroke
yes the good mark my ding-dong is joy be
so you can see properly there you go me
I would mark react to this me you're so
much better I can't do impressions man I
just can't
did I don't appreciate you making fun of
me like that
step it I'm so make it no nice okay I
have miss release oh no
hello content might say it's there I
know it's fine yeah that's a hard time
for you to do they jig it hello buck
climb that wire the fans are going wild
has never been stronger
nice leverage fun do it to me da da
do-do-do-do-do do-do subscribe how's it
going everyone my name is toby turner
here and gonna play some happy wheels
okay you always say how's it going
everyone for everybody I don't know
my god there we go Toby yeah do it do it
did and Q in it yeah we love this
youtuber it's by the way we love us
otherwise we wouldn't pick them that's
right
hex the uber hacks what does he say no
it doesn't have any weird catchphrase I
probably has I just don't need I need a
keyboard to smash while complain about
people will talk about Minecraft does
that what he does
oh yeah yes those I don't know that's
terrible
you did is really hard for me they're
waiting for that Toby Turner every time
all right
subscribe i do bi do bi do bi do
subscribe and outro of dog mr. butt slap
can't get over it
do it to me I'm doing it Oh take it Toby
oh it's gonna be possible
well it's cry by the way we've had your
crying
but I'd cry and today I'm gonna read you
something there was once a boy today
Marcia I'm gonna make all the fangirls
come
you want to hear my voice that's my real
voice
Manik right really it's like a
seven-year-old boy they use filter what
were these boys there's some shape
can you please fill it upward so I don't
have to go around everything hi hello
hey everyone and welcome to try place
over X or Nova you have right now oh
that's that's a boy it's probably a
weird bug I like a both mark and Toby
are touching my ding-dong I can probably
only say that one time in my life crap
very proud to say yeah just go up there
instead cry you must save me I can't
what Toby might yeah this is not okay
she's gonna flight me later
for real it's basically harm me it's
gonna sound like these but slaps that we
hear right now it's gonna it's gonna be
like that but it will probably echo all
the way to where you are I'll be still
there enjoy lunch and I hear oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] like my God my god
you'll do you like I have some
sunglasses to onto I'll be like my good
it's done this happened the day of the
d-day hey the ding-a-ling dong day yeah
yeah all right let's see if I can oh god
I had it one chance
I lost my current